well good morning everybody and welcome
to development control b
committee b my name is kathy guthrie and
i'm the chairman today
may i first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements
please ensure that microphones and
videos are turned off
when you are not speaking so
those of you who won't be speaking can
you turn your videos off please
that you do not interrupt the other
speaker
members are reminded not to use the
messaging or chat
function during the meeting and i will
be using the hands up
for declarations of pecuniary or
non-pecuniary interest
members are reminded that they should
not have alternative communication lines
open
i.e skype chats and that if you are
contacted by a third party during an
application
you should bring this to the legal
advisor's attention
but if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to leave
additionally you will be invited to
speak and ask questions by the chair of
the meeting please await your turn
we will not be using the hands up
function except for declarations of
interest
site visits pecuniary or non-pecuniary
interests lobbying and questions for
clarity
and after the first round i will use the
a to z for the first round
when we speak and after that we can use
the hands up function
if you are experiencing poor connection
issues in the first instance please turn
off your camera
if this does not work please turn off
all incoming video
these options are under the three dots
on the main information bar
mr bird can you turn off your video
please because you're not speaking
thank you i would like to remind
everyone present that this meeting will
be broadcast live to the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded
except where there are confidential
items if you make representations the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consented to being recorded
by the council
under the possible use of those sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
the council members of the public and
press may record
film photograph or broadcast this
meeting when the public and press are
not lawfully excluded
i'll make the introductions which is in
duprey our legal adviser
robert carmichael our governance officer
alex scott our case officer
area planning manager john paytman g and
we have the ward member councillor
andrew stringer
and just before i move to the agenda i
do make apologies there's rather a lot
of crashing and banging going on in the
background
i will try and mute my mic for most of
it but i've got workers on the roof
and everything is right by my window so
i apologize to everyone if there is a
noise
so we move on to the agenda apologies
for absence and substitutions
thank you joe i'll now conduct a role
call of members just to confirm who's
here so before we start we don't have
any apologies or substitutions so if you
could please respond with
uh good morning and present so
councillor james carsten
president councillor peter gould
president
how's the cathy guthrie president
councillor barry humphries
present counselor andrew mellon uh
president thanks robert council mike
norris president
council andrew stringer president the
council
boys present and i believe that
councillor geek has also
joined us as well this morning
yes i'm here i'll be leaving shortly
after i've just heard the introductory
things
thank you thank you council thank you
chair we are all here
right okay sorry that's just throwing me
a bit in what presents is councillor
geek joining us
uh council geek was um is war members
for the second item that will be
um deferred all right i understood thank
you very much for that clarity thank you
to receive declarations of pecuniary and
non-pecuniary interest by members
so you may use the hands up function any
no there are none declarations
of lobbying for this item are there any
declarations of
of lobbying which is the first item i do
beg your partner
no there are none declarations of
personal side visits
again oh counselor melon
council mellon can you explain you yes i
could just confirm
that i have had a look at the site when
passing thank you
all right thank you for that that's fine
and if you can take your hand down that
would be great
thank you confirmation of the minutes of
the meeting held on the 5th of august
and robert carmichael just wants to note
an amendment
thank you chair and there's just one
very slight amendment to
power to minute number 153.1
so where it reads the committee
adjourned for a short break between 1pm
and 110 prior to consideration of
application dc20154
after that i would ask that an amendment
be put to say
after the um after the um
break uh councillor kathy guthrie retook
the chair
that is all chair thank you for that can
i have a proposal
please two minutes hands up anybody yes
counselor casting hands up and a second
to please
and councillor norris thank you very
much indeed so do we go for a vote
please on this
a roll call thank you um robert
thank you chair
so if you could please respond with
fought against or abstain counts to
james carsten
caster peter gould four that's kathy
guthrie
four councillor barry humphries
four counts to andrew mellon four
counselor mike norris four councillor
andrew stringer
four
thank you chair that is carried so as
they've been confirmed they will be
signed
at the next practical opportunity thank
you
to receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme
and received chair um and before we
begin for the scheduler
applications we've received notice from
the governance
officer that item 7b dc one nine oblique
01876 expose grove lane elmsworth has
been withdrawn
from consideration today
with my agreement as detailed in
paragraph
14.13 of mid-suffolk planning charter
i will now ask the area planning manager
john patengi
to provide us with a short verbal update
as to why this decision
has been taken thank you
thank you and good morning members um so
we have received an extensive
uh letter from a third party and further
correspondence from the parish council
in regard to that to the application um
given
the judicial review history uh of this
particular
site and this application um and given
the content
of the third party representation uh
officers
seek withdrawal to have appropriate time
to review the correspondence received as
well as
consider any amendment necessary to
ensure a lawful
report is presented to members
a verbal update in respect to these
correspondence was considered but it was
not considered to be appropriate given
the
length of the correspondence received
and it would be a a better thing to do
to put it all into one report to ensure
members have
full consideration of the facts of the
case
on that basis uh it has been sought to
be withdrawn at this time
and ian thank you for that john and ian
can you just confirm there is no need
for
any voting on this matter i think
charter and constitution that provides
for this to happen it does happen from
time to time so
it's not necessary for a resolution to
be passed a journey
that you you have agreed with the
officers that it be withdrawn from
today's agenda and that's
um quite quite appropriate and i mean i
know the war one of the ward members is
here but
obviously she will have heard that and
that that's okay i assume
yes um and i will just ask the ward
member you had received that information
counselor geek and um apologies earlier
i thought
you may not have attended but i
understand your reasoning no i
i had received thank you chair and um i
just wanted
to to hear it myself in in full so thank
you very much and could i take this
opportunity to say goodbye then
thank you because you're not stopping
i'm not i'm not stopping i simply wanted
to to hear the reasons for this
withdrawal thank you thank you and the
parish council have
also heard this as well yes thank you
very much indeed
so we now move on to the um
next item 7a which is dc2001435
to the south of gibbing road stow upland
stone market and alex scott if you'd
like to introduce
the mata and put the screen forward for
everyone to see
thank you very much
[Music]
well thank you very much uh madam
chairman um
i don't believe that is deciding
question
gipping road stone market um
i believe um reading my charts here i do
beg your pardon it's dc1905949
which is i do beg your pardon i have
read it i'm looking for my chance here
um which is obviously at mendelssohn if
you'd like to clear that up i do
apologize
yeah of course just for clarity for
everybody
listening yes indeed indeed thank you
um yes so uh good morning um
madam chairman vice chairman members um
the application before you today is uh
application reference dc
oblique 19 oblique 05949
land to the west of mason court
commonly known as old engine meadow i
understand
in in mendelssohn the application
follows
outline planning permission reference
4242 oblique 16
approved by committee in february 2017
for 28 new dwellings that breaks down to
18
open market dwellings and 10 affordable
dwellings
and the application before you today
seeks approval of reserved matters
specifically matters of layout
scale appearance the new development
and the landscaping thereof and if i may
move to the
presentation i will try and present my
screen
hopefully everybody is able to see that
and we'll move to the slideshow
there we are hopefully that's clear for
everybody looking
in um so the for the avoidance of doubt
uh matters for consideration uh by
committee today
relate to the uh in orientation and
situation of buildings
roots and open spaces the height
width and length of each building
proposed
aspects of the building and place which
determine their visual impression
including external
built form architecture materials
decoration lighting color and texture
the treatment of
land other than buildings including
screen
fences and walls trees hedgerows shrubs
grass planting earthworks hard surfaces
and
amenity features
now uh by way of this current reserve
matters application
uh the local planning authority are
unable
um as set out in article 4 bracket 4 of
the act
the planning act unable to reconsider
matters including
principal the housing amount the housing
mix
number of affordable units renewable
energy and
uh biodiversity improvements um as set
out in that part of the act so just to
make sure that
it's clear what we are looking at
today um to the presentation for the
avoidance of doubt this is the location
of mendelssohn
within the district
and the approximate location
of the uh of the site within the village
itself
this is the site location plan approved
as part of the outline planning
permission
and the proposal site is outlined in
red for you there
these are the planning constraints
affecting the site
um as you can see the front part is
affected by
environment agency flood zones two
and three that's this area these blue
areas
part of the site lies outside of the
current local plan settlement boundary
which is defined by this
uh sort of ochre line here
so part inside
the part outside the green
hatched lines they denote
public rights of way in the area of the
site the purple line
denotes the boundary of the village
conservation area
and the coloured buildings indicate
buildings which
are listed on the national list
here is a aerial view a wider aerial
view of the
area of the village and then a more
localized view
this is the latest proposed site layout
revision p23
and a a more detailed view of the
northern portion
for you um which is predominantly where
the
uh where the market uh dwellings will be
uh
constructed and the market dwellings
that set out in the papers would be
four two bedroom dwellings ten three
bedroom dwellings
and four four bedroom dwellings
uh the public open space and drainage
infrastructure are proposed
to the frontage to the chapel road
frontage of the site
and estate roads and
paved footpaths uh
proposed linking from the the health
center here along the chapel road
frontage
through the site and there is also
a pedestrian access proposed via
mason court to the
to the center of the village
and the southern portion of the site
is where the affordable dwellings
will be proposed and there are ten
dwellings proposed there
uh four one bedroom flats which are
these two buildings here so one flat at
ground floor one flat at uh first floor
uh there are two two bedroom dwelling no
sorry one
correction one two bedroom dwelling
proposed and five
three bedroom dwangs proposed in terms
of the affordables
and just a bit more detail on the
pedestrian access
uh via masons court and uh
connections through uh horse fair close
and ducks and road to the village center
there um
this shows the proposed hard
landscaping throughout the site northern
portion
and southern portion
and then the proposed soft landscaping
into three areas for you there
and these are the uh elevations of the
dwellings proposed these are the
market dwellings uh plots one and eight
which is a four bedroom detached
dwelling
plot two four bedroom detached plot
three
three bedroom detached um
plots four and five which are three
bedroom detached
um plot seven
six and seven which are semi-detached uh
seven being three bedroom
um six four bedroom and plots twelve and
thirteen which are
two bedroom detached uh dwellings
um the remainder of the market dwellings
plot nine uh three bedroom detached
plots ten and eleven semi-detached
three-bedroom plots
fourteen and fifteen two-bedroom
semi-detached
plot 16 three-bed detached plot
17 three bed detached plot 18
three beds detached um
and the uh affordable dwellings proposed
uh we have a two bed um detached uh
property at uh plot 19 although attached
by the uh the side
uh element there and uh plots 20 and 21
which are three bedrooms semi-detached
plots 22 23 24 and 25 our
one bedroom flats uh one on ground floor
one above
and there are two of these buildings
proposed and finally
uh plots 26 27 and 28 uh
three bedroom dwellings in uh in a row
of uh
three three dwelling terrace there
and for completeness these are the uh
the garages um so single double
and uh a single and double
uh attached together uh which are
proposed throughout the site
excuse me and um we have some
street scene elevations for you um
this section a a is the main frontage
we then have section section b
which is the uh the next layer uh along
uh section c which is
uh looking uh in this direction and then
section d that way and then
section e which is the frontage of the
uh
affordable dwellings to the uh the south
of the site uh onto some uh photographs
for you this
is the uh excuse me
so this is the uh the entrance to mason
court and the the blue hours denote
where we are just for some uh reference
for you
so it's looking um into the site from
ducks and road into
mason court um looking up
ducks and road to one side and then the
other side of the
mason court access then uh
inside uh in front of the uh the garages
uh in association with mason court and
this is where pedestrians would
uh would emerge from the pedestrian
access which is
proposed and
looking back down um
that's the uh the uh existing uh
sheltered retirement complex which is uh
mason's
court um that is run by the council i
understand
and the garages
and this is a existing pedestrian access
from
mason court uh to uh the adjacent
housing estate at
horsefair close which is one of the
possible routes for pedestrians um
it will be coming from the site uh to
the center of the
of the village and
this is uh a view of the
uh of the rear of mason
court currently undefined
as you will as you will see
and looking the other way um
and this is towards uh
where the uh uh whether whether public
footpath proposed for path connection
will
um uh will exit the site and uh link
into the
existing development uh surrounding the
uh proposal site
and uh it's like a view to the rear
of the garages uh adjacent to mason
court
and um this area here i understand is
the uh
the common room in association with that
uh sheltered
retirement retirement housing
and we now move into the adjacent
housing estate at
uh horse fare close uh this is uh mason
court in the in the distance and um
the gap here between the uh existing
accommodation and the garage is where
pedestrians will be emerging and one of
the possible routes will be
uh this way it's a horse fair close
linking into
uh linking into the
uh uh existing village center there
and then uh just stepping back from that
a wider view of uh horse fare close
with mason's caught in the background
the pedestrian
uh link uh one of the possible emerging
sites
uh here and
um this location was one of the uh
original uh
one of the original proposed possible
pedestrian uh
accessors through to the site um between
these two
existing dwellings in what's very close
that uh has not come forward as part of
the reserve matters so that is
not proposed um currently for a
pedestrian access just to uh just to
make that uh clear
um we then move uh from horse fare close
to the south
to chapel road uh to the north and
um this photograph is taken from uh
the junction here looking at along
chapel road
to the uh to the west um
this is the uh junction to the
uh the health center and the site
you'll be able to see in the distance in
this location
and then uh the opposite view looking
back along
chapel road uh from the point of access
to the
the health center
and this is the existing
uh agricultural access
to the to the site um uh currently
grassed
but there is a new access proposed
along along here in this approximate
location
and just a final view across the
frontage of a site along chapel road
leading out of the village to the west
and a photo montage of the site frontage
finally and
an aerial view this was um
drawing footage taken as part of the the
outline application
that's that concludes the presentation
now the
officer recommendation as set out in the
papers is
uh the members delegate authority to the
chief planning officer
to approve reserve matters subject to
resolution of
technical details with regards drainage
basin design enclosure and management
and subjects to conditions as set out in
the papers
so i hope that recommendation is clear
thank you thank you for that alex
it's very helpful having the little
areas showing us where the photographs
and and where your presentation went
with the little
bits in the corner i thought that was
very useful um now if we want to go on
to
questions for clarity um not debate
obviously
for the planning officer i'm going to
try and keep up with you all
so if you'd like to use your hands up
we'll try that
this time round so i'm afraid i'll wait
for andrew to cancel a stringer until
the end if you don't mind but i notice
you're there
so if i can go first to counselor
norris and i apologize if i get the
order wrong so
counselor norris first hang on slow down
slow down
so councillor norris
and then um casting
and then councillor warboys
councillor gold um
slow down everybody right
i think that's fun and then councillor
humphreys
i can see councillor mellon's hand madam
sherman as well
oh right yes okay as i say they don't
come up in the order that they've come
out in so
let's go first with um councillor um
norris please
thank you uh where the pedestrian link
came through via mason's court i believe
it was slide
24 i
didn't observe any footpaths at that
point which would mean that
pedestrians would be emerging into an
area
where vehicles were maneuvering in and
out councillor norris we just want a
question where is their account
where is that where
then is are there any footpaths in that
area
where the link by a licensed court comes
through
for pedestrians into the garage area
where vehicles would be
maneuvering well
alex can you just show the thing rather
than debate it please
uh yes of course i'll just present my
screen with the photographs
[Music]
there we go uh right okay so this is
um no it's all right
the previous slide i think i think yes
previous one
one all right sorry there is a footpath
on the right hand side actually i can
see it now
that's fine you've answered my question
thank you what might help alex is if you
put a plan just to show the footways
which might
um alleviate some of the questions could
you just put a plan up showing the
footways please
uh yes
get back to the layout
yes
right so this uh this is the layout in
its uh
entirety so footways there will be a
proposed paved footway from the access
to the health center along chapel road
through the site and
by the estate roads and
there is then this uh pedestrian
footwear proposed
which will go via mason's court
and linking into the uh existing
footways which uh on mason's court
through to ducks and road and this
uh his accessories to horsepower's
clothes as well if that's
if that's helpful does that help it's
lenorous
yes that's fine i think that answers my
question thank you
thank you very much councillor casten
thank you very much madam chairman can
you take your hands down if you've
finished your question counsellor nice
sorry councillor caster
because i'm going to get in the muddle
with everyone counseling okay so
um yeah my question i i just like a bit
of clarity
there's two parts of this question but
i'll do them both at the same time
because i think they'll be
answered um both at the same time so um
this
site has a um hybrid suds
um attenuation basin um
i haven't come across a hybrid studs
before i'd like to um
know a bit more why it's a hybrid and
why it's what makes it a hybrid and why
it's a standard um
well it's not a standard one the um and
leading on from that the the flood and
water management
have come back with a holding objection
to this
um there's not a huge amount of detail
on that in these papers and i wonder if
um
i could have a bit more detail and a bit
more clarity on that as well please
thank you
okay if i may madam chairman yeah yeah
please answer it yeah
yeah okay um yes
yes well in terms of um the uh the
hybrid system
um i mean that simply relates to um
a combination of um water
um water retention um
on the site by way of the uh attenuation
basin
and then um controlled
discharge into uh adjacent watercourses
um
whereas a uh you know a complete system
would
um simply allow all uh surface water to
drain to ground
uh within the site so uh that's the uh
the hybrid
system uh proposed um in terms of the
local lead flood authority's objection
um
yes that that is still to be resolved
and part of the
uh the recommendation before you is that
um
uh we delegate power to the chief
planning officer to mr isabel to uh
uh resolve these these technical um
uh details before uh final approval
so that's that's part of the
recommendation if that's helpful
james can i just come back before you do
uh make a comment on it
um i i queried the same thing myself um
in our briefing
and what the we've got at the moment in
the um
uh recommendations at the back and
conditions
is there's a sort of a tacit agreement
that if it's not satisfactory then it
won't go ahead
um and it's more detail required so
that's where it sits at the moment
so um so to clarify that this will not
be
approved unless the um suffolk county
council flood and water management
say we're leaving it we're leaving it
with the planning officer to determine
it um on the if members are minded to
approve it
we're leaving it to the lead officer to
satisfactorily resolve that issue
okay okay thanks thanks councillor war
boys
yeah hi thank you thank you chair
um yes it's a there's a document from um
2014 that deals with the planning of
um affordable housing
and it talks about the integration of
affordable housing does that
um it's six years old this document does
this
does it document still apply to this
scheme
alex or john can you help us with that
one i'm not quite sure that what the
relevant
it says to do with um how the
name of the document was yes yeah it's
uh i've got the the yeah
it's something strategic it's strategic
planning
um ahspd final
february 2014.
it talks about pepper potting
yeah that's what i thought you were on
about pepper potting yeah no we're not
doing that
yeah go on john that's all right um
ultimately
uh that isn't an adopted uh document as
far as this council is concerned
um but in terms of relevant material
consideration
there is some weight that can be given
to that i would say though
it is our general approach not to
keep all the affordable housing on one
side of the development and put all the
market housing in the other
because of the need for social
integration
and that is a clear uh planning goal
that we have been
uh dealing with for for many years now
um
in this particular case i don't feel
that we have a particular issue
there is a conflict though with uh
pepper potting versus uh
grouping of uh affordable housing in
that housing associations
don't want to take on housing that is
split apart all over the estate
they actually prefer groups of houses
so that it's easier for them to maintain
and manage
and it's easier for them to to deal with
ownership
considerations so there is always a bit
of a tussle
about trying to ensure that affordable
housing is adequately spread out across
an estate
um at the same time is reasonable for
the housing associations to take on
board
um but you know it is a judgment and i
subject a subjective one
um i think given the the size of this
particular development
and the way that all the pedestrian
routes and the layout
uh integrates with each other i would
not say there'd be a
an immediate concern that the affordable
housing has been segregated to one side
and kept out of her sight
john wells that's helpful we're almost
into debate on that one
thank you very much yeah thank you for
your question thank you
um councillor gould
thank you uh chairman in fact council
warboys
has just raised the matter i was going
to ask about but i have another
quick one which is uh has the uh concern
of waste services in terms of
accessibility
for uh waste refuge collection vehicle
been met
um yes yes that has been addressed in
the in the final layout so that's
uh that's to their satisfaction now
there were just a couple of plots where
the
um the the pickup the bin pickups were
uh
um not seen as ideal but uh that has now
been resolved
to my understanding thank you
thank you for that councillor humphreys
mom chair thank you it's just a question
just in case i forgot but it's um
regarding a strategic housing comment
holding
objection how many two-bedroom houses
are there and how many one-bedroom flats
i might have got it i've just i just
missed it
okay just for confirmation
um in terms of um the
the market housing there are four
two-bedroom
dwellings and in terms of the affordable
housing there are four
one-bedroom flats and one two-bedroom
house thank you
and councillor mellon please
uh yeah thank you chair um i've got a
couple of three questions here
well if you can be brief because the
only for clarity if you would
yeah um in terms of the access uh the
pedestrian access and i think that's
largely been
uh answered um the the parish council
had a question about a path
from plot three which seemed to go
nowhere and i can't work out which
one is plot three and if we could just
have clarity on that one
secondly the potential
sort of pedestrian connection in the far
south west of the site
which um i think alex showed on a
photograph
which was then sort of discounted it
does seem a shame that that
hasn't been able to come forward and i'd
like to know why that wasn't possible
and then moving to a separate issue is
concern about building on a flood plain
obviously we're clearly right in the
floodplain two and three
at the the north end of the site i can't
just have clarification
that we're seeking to address that by
remodeling the water course i think
that's what i understand from the papers
thank you chad thank you thanks can you
answer those for us please
uh yes yes certainly um i believe the uh
parish council's concern with the the
footpath that
led to um apparently nowhere was uh
in this location adjacent to plot three
um it simply connects to the uh to the
road and then
uh adjacent to the site
um yes no
perhaps the um the applicant can clarify
that a bit further why that is proposed
but
um i can i can see their point that um
it does apparently
um not lead to anywhere
uh that specific um now
the um in terms of the
um the footpath uh connection uh
in this location that was considered
at uh at outline stage but it has not
come forward in terms of
reserve matters and
i'm not sure of the uh exact reasons why
that is
um and perhaps that that is a question
for
uh um for the applicant but uh there are
a couple of options at uh outline stage
and this has been
selected as the preferred preferred
route and
uh that's what has come forward for us
today
um in terms of the the flood zone to um
uh to the north of the site um
the uh the converting and the
attenuation the
the drainage um has all been proposed in
order to
mitigate that um but uh
those issues still need to be
finally resolved and
again that goes back to uh to our
recommendation that
we still need to do some work on this as
officers and
the chief planning officer will be uh
will be managing that
hopefully that's okay
um right who we got um
we now have um i'll ask my question
later
um so counselor stringer if you'd like
to ask your question for clarity please
do
yes could i have clarity on the
difference between
slide 10 and slide 12.
slide 10 differs from slide 12
regarding potential access to horse fare
clothes
i don't want to get into debate about
why we
wish to see that stopped up i'll do that
in my speech if that's all right
but yeah i would like to know which plan
we're working to slide 10 or slide 12
because they radically differ
okay yes um well well slide 10 is the uh
southern portion of the
proposed layout so that is the uh
the layout which is proposed site 12
yeah can i stop and point out what the
difference is
of course that's good if you if you look
at the
on slide 10 don't be there yet if you
look at the
where it meets horse fair close there
are no gates or any breaks
in that boundary if you go to slide 12
there are two gates in it
okay so the slide 12
shows the hard landscaping proposals so
if there were any
gates proposed they would be shown on
slide 12.
right so can i ask you which one are we
working to
uh in terms of proposed gates it would
be slide 12
hard landscaping right okay
so slide 12 shows and access into horse
fare clubs
right because it shows a a gate in the
corner
there's a gate in the corner okay
well can you not see it you can have
clarity from the
applicant from the application
again it's very important because people
have written in about it
and they've been trying to come in here
may i have a comment yes yes john i know
you've got something to help
um so this is reserved matters
uh in respect of appearance landscaping
layout and scale not access and that
includes pedestrian
so access is not before us to determine
ultimately the point here
is that we can deal with the
landscaping and hard landscaping and
fencing and so on but we can't deal with
the actual access points in principle
so whatever has been agreed to outline
and
ultimately that deal with dealt with
that outline in terms of access is dealt
with by outline this reserve matters is
not
that remit to decide how to access this
site
um however there would be in terms of
boundary treatment if there was a
question
about the appearance of landscaping on a
particular
point of a boundary then we need some
clarification about that
that's what we need to find and we can
determine that as necessary
right okay does that cancel a stringer
and then you
can ask the applicant the further
information that you're speaking
absolutely so the question is is there
or is there not a gate
in that boundary treatment
alex can you just point out specifically
where we're talking about because i'm
slightly well i presume what
from what councillor council is saying
it's uh this location here
yeah um
is that right councillor stringer it's
that bit there that you're concerned
yeah correct uh slide 12 shows two gates
slide 10 shows no gates at all and do we
have a visual
in a photograph on that particular area
i think we do
don't we yes we do i just um
which might help us focus on what we're
talking about
there is that the one councillor
stringer yeah that's correct
that's correct yeah i'd spotted that in
fact i've made a note of that is
um i might ask the question in a minute
myself councillor stringer if you've
finished now with your questions
and those can you take your hands down
spoken please
um yeah i was going to ask a question am
i correct in thinking that that
gate or the footpath is in the ownership
of mid-suffolk district council am i
right or am i wrong i could have
misunderstood that in our briefing
perhaps somebody could help me please
um yes i mean from the from the
application forms i understand the
uh the southern part of the uh the site
is
within uh council ownership yeah so was
that gate
which is the the one that councillor
stringer is referring to would that gate
be in
suffolk county amid suffolk's ownership
i beg your pardon
uh that's what the application uh seems
to show chair yeah okay
right so we we've we've had a bit of a
debate on that one but that was the
question
um i do have a question on slide 18 if
you would please
um which is um between the plots
19 to 20 i'm only asking it just for
for for what it is is you mentioned
there's a bit of a link
what what is that bit of a link is it is
it um a utility room or something like
that between the two do we know or is it
again that i should ask the applicant
it's not great relevance but i was just
curious
yeah i believe that there are utility
rooms but perhaps uh we could
ask the applicant for clarity on that
that's what it okay
on the floor plans yeah right lovely
right well we'll crack on then
um we now have the parish council thank
you for to everybody
um the parish castle representative
um and we have mr mike xle
and um our officer will advise you when
you're
nearly up to your three minutes and um
if you'd like to introduce yourself put
your microphone on and
and your video and we'll have a look and
see who you are thank you very much
are you there i'm here can you hear me
yes
yes did you want to okay
thank you chair very kind thank you um
but mendelssohn parish council has
supported this application now for some
three years
it represents some of the last land
available with us within our settlement
boundary
plus what we know as the old engine
meadow which provides the road access
it does conform to our existing
neighbourhood plan and also forms part
of our draft revised neighbourhood plan
currently in circulation we knew from
the beginning that flooding
and road surface water would be a
problem
but hope that with a good drainage plan
this could be solved and also correct
the bad
surface water flooding at the entrance
to the health center
this applicant has always been very
cooperative
and has attended various open meetings
we have held in the village
and taken on board many of our concerns
as a parish
and we hope that with further
cooperation and goodwill all round
that this application can be brought to
a satisfactory conclusion
and approved thank you for listening
thank you very much indeed that was very
succinct
um now be gentle with me when you want
questions does anybody have questions
please
the parish counsellor no that's
absolutely fine thank you for your input
mr xle
thank you thank you
uh we don't have an objector or
supporter so we now
have the applicant jamie bird and you
have three minutes as well if you'd like
to put your microphone
and um mr xle if you'd like to um take
your
video off please and we'll have mr bird
please
thank you and good morning my name is
jamie bird and i'm the
land and planning director for fleur
homes
we are an award-winning house builder we
undertake a number of developments
across the region
where the focus is good design we are
also working with the sandringham estate
in norfolk
on our portfolio projects where the
focus as you might imagine is quality
and we want mendelssohn to be no
different
this isn't our first venture into
suffolk but it is into mendelssohn
the village is very important to me
personally as i've lived in the village
for
some seven years a very fond memories of
mendelssohn and this is one of the
reasons i
persuaded my co-directors to look at
this site
and notwithstanding its challenges we
are very keen to move forward with the
development of this land
you'll see the application has been
generally well received locally
and we have addressed many of the points
raised by statutory council teams
in terms of the points raised by
councillors i'd like to just comment as
follows
in terms of surface water we've worked
hard to design a system that works
and addresses both the needs of the site
and those experienced locally
these obviously will be addressed by the
chief planning officer should you
approve today
also in terms of the footpath in front
of plot three
this can be removed if of concern to
councillors it would appear it was a
hangover from an original design
uh in terms of the footpath to the south
of plot 28 and nearest the historic
pedestrian access to horsepower close we
can ensure that there's a gravel margin
and remove any sense of footpath there
the gates that are shown we think are
actually again
a historic left over from an original
drawing so again just to be clear
those gates will be removed and fenced
off there is no access
in terms of the point made between plots
19 and 20
uh again actually that there isn't a
formalized link there it is actually
just gates
so um the drawing needs to be amended
but
um that roofscape is isn't uh
yeah shouldn't be shown so it is just a
pedestrian uh to a gateway link a fence
link between the two
so fundamentally the site is deliverable
and we are keen to get started
having discharged a number of the
outline planning conditions
and this obviously reserve matters
application is the most significant
your officer recommends approval and i
hope you'll support his recommendation
and approve the application today
obviously very happy to answer any
questions you may have thank you
thank you mr bird that's very helpful um
now question whoops yes questions
uh for mr bird but i would point out
that he does seem to have picked up
on some of the questions that we did
earlier for which i'm grateful
and hopefully that resolves uh some of
the issues that we had there
so councillor mellon you've put your
hand up for a question would you like to
ask your question please
uh yes thank you chair so it's just
another
question for clarification on the
flooding risk um
everybody seems to think that this is
about the surface water from this site
and adjacent but the the the environment
agency
floodplain is is to do with water coming
down from upstream
not from this site um
so can you just give me a little bit
more um clarity on what you're planning
to do
can i just ask a question before mr bird
answers that question and i'll ask that
question of uh
john payton g it's not up to this
development to sort out what's coming
from upstream am i correct in that
john
this is difficult because obviously we
have to deal with an application and
the control of that application and we
are dealing with other authorities that
would
deal with the management and
responsibility of the anything upstream
so i would probably say no there's
nothing we can
pursue in that respect yeah i thought
because i think that's putting mr bird
on
on the spot over something that's out of
theirs in our hands
um having thought about it councillor
malone would you agree with that
i'm just thinking about chair to um a
previous application that we discussed
on the other side of the road
where there was a long debate about the
fact that we were going to build
on the edge of the flood plain now here
we're actually building in the flood
plain
and i just need to sort of have a bit of
clarity about um how we're
planning to deal with it
sorry madam chair if i come in it's not
it wouldn't be wrong to invite mr bird
to answer that question as best he's
able to as long as you yeah yeah
i i i just didn't think it was fair to
put him on the spot for something that
was outside his control
but mr bird and and ian dupri's uh input
thank you for that mr bird could you
pass comment please
i can um obviously past the original
outline there was
extensive modelling hydraulic modelling
undertaken
above the water course
and um our proposals
in fairness at that outline stage they
the modelling was
generally undertaken to counter to to
deal with
because of its historic nature to deal
with the one in 50-year storm
now formerly being a resident of
mendelssohn
and knowing it as i do and obviously
often going to the health center i do
know
that in front of the health center
periods of heavy rainfall
it does get very flooded and there are
large puddles there
so the way that we approach this
application was to
immediately move to design the scheme to
achieve the latest standards not being
asked to do so but to
achieve the latest standards required by
the local flood authority
which is the achieving the one in 100
year storm requirement
uh plus climate change so that's the way
the scheme has been designed so
attenuation based on the uh the
profiling of the
ditch have all been modeled
to reflect those latest standards
the questions and the holding objections
that come from the local flood authority
principally relates to the
the implementation of a management plan
for the
construction of the attenuation basin
at the point of you know the point at
which it's constructed i.e the first
thing that's built on site
so that it is ready and able to deal
with
those surface water events and obviously
is there
established and available to accommodate
any drainage
once the scheme is obviously up and
running in terms of construction
so it has all been hydraulically
modelled um
we didn't quite make committee we've had
a meeting with the local flight
authority and your officers
hence why obviously the the matter has
been delegated to the head of planning
to deal with post
this committee meeting but i think and i
hope that that addresses
um your question there is one point i'd
just also like to make that
i meant to mention in my speech just
very quickly it was about affordable
housing mix
um the mix that was set out by
uh alex scott originally wasn't quite
accurate um in that alex suggested there
was only one
two there the four one beds and one two
bed there are actually
four two beds uh and four one beds
so um and two two beds so that that's
the that
is the actual mix there are more two
beds than alex was first suggesting
and i allowed you to do that you did
have an extra 30 seconds that you hadn't
used up earlier so i think that was a
very useful
useful thing because we need accuracy
and thank you for for correcting on that
so councillor mellon i think um
hopefully that's satisfied your inquiry
a little better yes thank you thank you
chair for letting me pursue that
no no no no i mean i i did all of it in
the briefing and i didn't get as much as
you got out of it so
we didn't have mr bird there either
obviously uh councillor casten you have
a question if you would please
thank you very much thank you very much
madam chairman
yeah it's some following on from
councillor mellon some question on the
drainage so this is a um
hybrid sud system so as well as
containing the water it
um attenuates into
the stream do you have the figures on
the release rate
of that hybrid um sud system
um compared with
what the runoff would be normally off
the site now
are we are we reducing staying the same
or are we increasing the runoff
into the um stream
um i i can't give you the specific
numbers but i know that the requirements
of the lead local flood authority
um and the design of the system is to
meet
the runoff rate of the the field
as it is so it is to to ensure that it
is no more
than is currently experienced but what
we're in what we are doing as part and
parcel of these proposals is endeavoring
to alleviate the localized flooding that
often occurs
um in front of and around the uh
the entrance to the health center so we
are looking to improve
the situation as it's currently designed
but it does
meet the requirements of the lead local
flood authority in that way
may i come in on that chair yeah yeah
james can you take a hand
just direct just to add to that um the
suffolk county east requirement is
actually a 10
increase uh in terms of improvement
to any particular existing uh capacity
so therefore
uh the expectation would be that new
development would
in terms of its runoff would be 10
better eg
you would reduce the runoff by at least
10 percent because
that would help um alleviate any flood
issues so their their actual standard is
is a 10 improvement it's not just a
status quo
it's an improvement by 10 that's their
current guidance to what they worked in
thank you very much for that i think all
those questions were very valid and very
clearly answered
hopefully everybody's happier with the
outcome of that
and so we now come on to the ward member
councillor stringer if you'd like to
tell us
about the site please thank you yeah
thank you thank you chair
uh i'll i'll tidy up a couple of bits
before i uh
go in between outline and detail
there has been a little bit of work
carried out in this area
one of which was to a culvert to
actually alleviate some of the flooding
and and one of the things done in
between was a
was a extension to parking provision at
the health center
which has been most gratefully received
because men from health center has been
dealing with bactons
health over the covet period uh
also to clear up about the flooding
where it says 49.7 meters on slide eight
that is where there was a blockage a
couple of years ago
which has now all that ditch has now
been dredged out which has actually
improved
the lot of chapel road in terms of
flooding uh just to show you how it's
all interlinked
uh if i could also have the picture of
horse fare close and the two driveways
that'd be really helpful because i'd
just like to
quickly go over why we quashed the idea
of an
access into horse fare close it was
because under the right to buy the two
houses
either side was sold and mid suffolk
gave those people the right to park on
that driveway
which meant actually if you did allow
people to walk in and out of that area
they would quickly get run over and
they'd have to wiggle in between cars
and the whole thing was a nightmare so
everyone agreed right from the outset
that we we would seek
an alternative entrance uh pedestrian
entrance other than the one from
horsefair close and the one proposed
is more central and it wires off into
two directions and is far more
preferable
to the vast majority of residents in
mendelssohn
this particular site is a major piece in
the jigsaw for mendelssohn's built
future
a third of the site has been inside the
1998 local plan
and the whole of the site is in the
draft joint local plan as well in the
draft allocations policy
for the mendelssohn neighborhood plan
this is a very
high quality development uh on the
northern exposed edge of this parish
so the fact that the buildings are very
high quality
it is really good in this location
because this will be an entrance
gateway site in into the village
there's also you might as well there's a
need for this substation
in the field next door that's because
nearly all of these houses will have air
source heat pump heating systems
so sustainability has been a key as
we've been going through
trying to deliver this site uh and as i
said earlier we've had
we've already had some work done on to
the water courses uh
frankly uh my my life and mendelssohn's
life would be an awful lot better if
every developer acted like this one
in terms of bringing all their ideas to
us early
uh frankly uh you know mendelssohn needs
this to deliver its housing numbers
and i would urge all of the committee
members to uphold the recommendation of
our officers
thank you chair thank you very much any
questions for councillor stringer
no andrew you've got off lightly so we
now move to debate if i can go through
the a to z
um if i can do it that way first time
round and then
if you want to put up
proposals after we've all spoken
including myself
then we can look at that so um
who wants to um come in i think john
might want to just
alter a recommendation a couple of
things on the recommendation do you want
to
do that now and then members might not
hate it
yeah i think uh given what i've heard um
if i may come in this is
unusual to do this but i think it may
save a little bit of time
if i may add a condition to the current
officer recommendation
and that condition being uh
notwithstanding details on the boundary
to the south
uh that there shall be no gate leading
to between
number 35 and 36 horse fare close
that therefore should allow us to ensure
that that is a fence
only along that boundary treatment i
hope that would be acceptable if i
uh ensure that we don't have a gate that
leads to the path between number 35
and 36 horsepower close that we secure
continued fencing instead and that was
obviously picks up on the landscaping
boundary treatment
that was questioned earlier and uh
possibly resolves the access point by
default
i think that's very sensible to do that
and as we go through the debate i'm sure
members
will either comment or approve it so i'm
happy at this point for you to add that
so that members can degrade so let's go
uh round first of all um councillor
casten would you like to open the debate
for us please
thank you madam chairman um so my major
concern
with this um is the
floodplain the um the drainage issue
it seems to me um council stringers
said the work's been done blockage has
caused
more of a flood plain there than maybe
um
the modeling suggests if that's if
that's correct
um we have to be really careful
with flooding it's destructive
it it pollutes and
it's it's terrible for people it would
be a failure
to build to allow planning to um
be building to be carried out on a flood
plain
i am happy to leave this to the
officers as delegated um authority on
this
um i'm i know they'll um i know they'll
take it very
seriously the um apart from
that flooding issue as long as we can
get something that we know is not going
to flood
um within a few years of building
and um cause all those problems i'm
i'm happy with this um these reserve
matters
thank you thank you councillor casten
councillor gould
thank you chair um i i think this is um
application of considerable merit uh
there's a good provision
of uh of affordable homes
it's supported by the the parish uh i
think cancer custom
uh is right really the only uh hesitance
is is around the flooding but i'm
confident that
uh the officers um will
ensure that uh the required
scheme is is agreed before
the development takes place but i think
this is uh
this is a very good development thank
you
thank you councillor gould councillor
humphreys
thank you it's really nice actually to
get an application where everybody seems
to be in agreement for once so
well done um including the local
councils which is fantastic and the
people we should listen to
um i've got no real concerns with this
at all uh i agree with the
condition the additional condition with
regards to the footpath 35-36 uh
horse care close i think that's a an
appropriate thing to do and we should we
should add that
um if we go forward um the housing mix
is fine
the footpaths again that's been dealt
with and in terms of flooding and also
the
um surface drainage that's already a
condition
for the senior planning officer to deal
with so it's already in there and
obviously it wouldn't go ahead unless
that was up to the right standard so
i've got confidence in her offices i've
got confidence
in the conditions i've got confidence in
the fact that that will be dealt with
before
before planning begins or building
begins sorry
so yeah it's a good application and i'm
minded to support it as we go along
thank you
thank you for that councillor humphreys
council of norris
councillor norris are you there do you
want to say something
sorry my laptop decides to go on a go
slow
don't worry yeah uh no real concerns
i did have one or two questions but
they've already been answered
i'm much reassured by the applicant's
presentation and by the ward members
support for the application so i will
probably
be supporting the recommendation thank
you
thank you um i'm just looking
um counselor um war boys if you would
please
yes i think i can echo counselors
stringer's work there's been a lot of
good
uh consultation between um flood
flow homes and meddlesome parish council
they've produced a scheme that
appears to keep everyone happy
i think in looking thinking looking
again at what it says about affordable
housing and the design the
i think visually the tenure blind i
think the um
facades of the buildings sort of sh of
the different um housing schemes are
integrated
to each other and apart from the
positioning i think that they will be
well integrated
uh flooding and the footpath issue seems
to resolve
i i'm assuming that there are some
recommendations about biodiversity
enhancement and um
the uh the recommendations from peter
chisholm all about
water energy and resource efficiency
have been reserved
but um apart from that then i've got no
further comments
thank you for that um
counselor melon
your girl sorry i decided to put you out
of order to confuse you
thank you for that um yes um
obviously um largely in support of this
application just to pick up on the point
that councillor warboys just made and i
was going to make the same point
um peter chisnall on page 73
74 of the bundle um has made some
suggestions in terms of conditions and
in fact he's recommending refusal if
those are not put in place now we have
got
i think eight or nine pages of
conditions in
in the officer's recommendation but i
can't quite see
where um the environmental
uh concerns are coming through and maybe
um
john pate mangy can sort of just clarify
on that but um
it would be nice to see them sort of in
there amongst the other conditions
thank you
[Music]
i think um one of the issues is we're at
reserve matters and i think john will
explain it in a little
greater detail for us
yeah well in a nutshell that is where we
are um ultimately
um you're dealing with today is scale
access appearance
and landscaping you're not a layout for
that matter
you're not dealing with how
environmentally friendly the property
should or shouldn't be
um that needs to be a matter of uh
outline planning permission um and you
know
for example um if you if you take solar
panels
um you know can you refuse a reserve
matters application because it fails to
have solar panels
uh in the mix of the proposal well
the lack of something doesn't offend
appearance it doesn't offend layout
scale or access or landscaping
um you know there's nothing to be judged
there because it's just not being
proposed
if we wanted it to be in the mix for
judgment
it needed to be controlled to be there
via the outline
planning permission as part of the
principle of allowing that development
to take place
um on this land you know the the
there is no expectation when an outline
is granted
of the developer owner to come forward
with those provisions because they
haven't been set out
in the outlying uh application so i
appreciate my colleague in respect of
his recommendation
but in planning terms we have to
appropriate that to the right stage
and that would either be an outline
application or a full application
not a reserve matters which only deals
with uh the the issues of uh
appearance and landscaping layout and so
on and in this particular case
access has already also been dealt with
at uh
outline level as well so we have less to
deal with in respect to this reserve
matters application
thank you john but i think it's fair to
say that since
matters have changed over several years
and
that's where people are getting confused
as to when and where these sorts of
things come up
and i know you've sent me a very helpful
aid memoir which might prove beneficial
to all members to be sent out at some
stage
on that but i understand councillor
mellon's views
um and probably when this was set up in
the first place we didn't have the
availability to do that so
um hopefully this explains it a little
bit better yeah i will i will pick that
up um just to mention
that the the problem here is that in
three years
um we've had a shift and
and part of that is climate emergency
and so on but we have had a shift in
in emphasis and of course we are now
picking up in
outline more things that we should be
picking up which is
biodiversity improvements to a degree
renewable energy
to a degree and even the housing mix as
well in terms of market housing mix
now you will see on any outlines
hopefully that come forward to you
from now or for the last year at least
they will have
conditions in respect of those issues
being recommended to members the problem
we've got at the moment
is that three years ago we weren't
looking at those issues
as we are now and we are now dealing
with the reserve matters of those
outlines that were granted three years
ago
it will be another year or so before you
get to see the reserve matters
come forward that have been picking up
on the outlines that we are dealing with
today
yeah thanks for that john and i can see
councillor mellon nodding his head
and i'm in agreement with him too on the
on the issues that are changing
minute by minute as we know uh right
thank you for that counselor melan um
i think that's everybody who's spoken
myself
i don't know what that was not me
um myself yes when i first read the
papers um
i i did sort of double takes on several
of the things
holding objections all sorts of things
um again
councillor casten and others have
brought up about the flooding but when
you hear what what's really been going
on in the background
and what conditions we've got put in
place it covers everything
very nicely i i really do hope this is
a good exemplar of a development when it
goes forward because
i will be supporting it so if anyone
wants to make a recommendation and
no need to speak any further oops i see
councillor humphreys i did see that one
and councillor cast so um all the other
councillors and uh councillor stringer
it looks like we've got something
positive here councillor humphreys
uh mum sure yeah indeed i believe we do
um i would like to move for
recommendation of approval
um with conditions laid out on page 35
36 an additional condition written by mr
paint g
regarding the um no gate
on the footpath between 35 and 36 horse
care clothes
if that can be added then i'd move
approval thank you for that and
councillor carsten
yes happy to second that right in that
case then um may
um the um committee officer do a roll
call
on the decision
just briefly if i may um just for the
benefit of anyone who might be watching
this and
um comparing and checking up up things
just uh
mr carmichael if you can confirm i've
got this right obviously this is an
eight-member committee
which normally include includes for full
purposes councillor andrew stringer but
under this council's rules which are not
universal
in all over england a ward member who
happens to be on the committee is
allowed to speak as he
she would be if they weren't on the
committee but they do not vote
and it is normally made very obvious
when they're in the council chain
because they sit apart but when we're
lying that can get lost so if that that
mr carmichael i've got that right for
this committee haven't i
that is correct mr duprey and that will
be noted in the minutes as well
um for for clarity for all and there are
other councils that do work on this
basis as well i i happen to know one or
two but
it's a very valid point for everybody to
listen
yeah thank you so roll call away please
thank you chair so if members could
please respond
as earlier with fought against or
abstain
cats james carson four
councilor peter gould four
counts of kathy guthrie four
councillor barry humphries paul
councillor mike norris four
chancellor roland warboys
think how's the melon four
thank you chair that is carried yes
thank you very much for everyone there
are no further
um matters that we need to discuss i
don't believe we've got any site visits
planned robert
so on that basis i close the meeting
thank